[Música]
por fin después de tanto tiempo se nos
mostró el primer vistazo al rey 78 y
sobre todo la nueva playstation ya que
es unos días mediante una transmisión en
vivo el equipo de playstation decidió
por fin revelar cómo sería el salto
hacia la nueva generación pues dentro de
este anuncio también se regalaron varios
juegos que francamente se ven asombrosos
dentro de los cuales destacan restante 8
y obviamente la revelación de la propia
consola la playstation 5
a pesar de que en esta misma transmisión
hubieron varios anuncios cubriendo
juegos que están geniales en este vídeo
quiero centrarme solamente en reset
antiguo otro
hace poco más de un año cubrir un vídeo
los rumores que hasta ese momento se
conocían de resident y 28 rumores que su
mayoría se ha confirmado con el tráiler
que se mostró la presentación de
playstation hace un par de días
como dije más de un año pasado y desde
entonces más allá de que el taller haya
sido oficialmente revelado hay más
información de este juego así que
analicemos lo más relevante de este
tráiler y la nueva información que
tenemos por ahora hawit
ya desde hace mucho tiempo se venía
rumoreando el inminente anuncio de nuevo
a ver si está vivo y con playstation
también anuncia lo que harían la
revelación de su nueva consola en una
transmisión en vivo era bastante claro
que era en ese momento que revelaría en
el juego e incluso se llegó a rumorear
la idea de un nuevo silent hill que
sería presentado en este mismo streaming
pero de momento lo único que ha visto la
luz es rue 78 que después de muchos
rumores por fin se ha confirmado con un
breve trailers unos de los pequeños
visitados a la ambientación del juego
algunos de sus enemigos y sus personajes
principales pero comencemos con los
primeros segundos del tráiler ya que
éste comienza con un texto donde se nos
dice literalmente su historia llega a un
final aquí es donde podemos dar riendas
bastantes teorías pues en primer lugar
no se les menciona a quien se refieren
con estas palabras ya están crisis o tal
vez algún otro personaje que
probablemente vea su final en este juego
más adelante y a lo largo de la mayoría
de este tráiler de lo más relevante que
podemos rescatar son las escenas donde
se nos muestran distintos personajes y
enemigos que tendrá el juego de donde se
pueden reconocer algunos habitantes de
la aldea donde tomará lugar la historia
a una anciana que parece ser un tipo de
bruja que según rumores estas brujas
tendrán la capacidad de invocar o llamar
a varios enemigos entre ellos los
hombres lobo
más adelante vemos a bastantes enemigos
como por ejemplo a unas mujeres que
tienen una apariencia de no ser muy
amigables
de que una de ellas pueda parecer
manipular insectos o algún tipo de
plagas muy similar a como lo hacían
margaret baker en el juego anterior
veamos al tan especulado hombre lobo que
la verdad luce bastante bien en una
breve escena lo vemos de nuevo pero esta
vez acompañado por algo muy similar a
los ejecutores de jueces nivel 5 una
criatura enorme con lo que parece ser un
mazo gigante por unos pocos segundos se
le da bastante atención al ministerio su
personaje el que lamentablemente no
tenemos nada de información pero luce
como alguien bastante enigmático y muy
importante para la trama y en mi opinión
lo hace como si este tipo fuera a ser
que nos ayude a lo largo del juego
ofreciéndonos armas y cualquier otro
objeto que nos pueda ser de ayuda en la
historia algo así como el mercadeo cero
es de nivel 4
en este primer vistazo también se nos
aclararon varias cosas como por ejemplo
el hecho de que izan winter el personaje
principal de resident y vos 7 repetirá
como protagonista además estar
acompañado por otro personaje muy
conocido por los fans chris redfield
pero esta vez tendremos un crisis muy
distinto al de apariencia chistosa que
vemos en restrictivos 7 al parecer su
apariencia clásica y mamady sima volverá
para haciéndose bastante que vimos en
vendetta pero no sólo eso porque lo que
nos da entender el tráiler es que el
papel de crisis era un poco distinto
porque usualmente tiene en otros juegos
ya que pasará de ser un héroe con pechos
de acero a lo que parece uno de los
antagonistas del título pues después de
salvar la vida ahí están en el juego
anterior parece que se va a pasar todos
los actos heroicos por el mismísimo
ojete porque en cierta parte del tráiler
después de pedirle perdón agitan
chrysler dispara a sangre fría a mía y
llámame loco pero dispararle a una mujer
indefensa no es muy de héroes que
digamos pero tal vez es sólo cosa mía en
un vídeo creado por los desarrolladores
donde cuentan más detalles del juego no
se creerán que la historia de recibo 8
transcurre algunos años después del
final del séptimo juego con ethan y mía
viviendo una nueva y tranquila vida
hasta que llega a crisis quien por algún
motivo será la razón de que la tranquila
vida de italcambio y se vea envuelto en
esta nueva y macabra historia
esto puede que tenga una aplicación
menos malvada y tal vez los actos de
cristian por una buena razón que no se
nos cuentan el trailer pero de momento y
considerando todo esto y el hecho de que
crist ahora trabaja para esta nueva
hombre la las cosas no se ven muy bien
para él es más en una imagen promocional
del título se nos muestra este personaje
con un aura muy oscura por ahora muy
pronto para especular sobre el papel que
tendrá este personaje por las cosas
apuntan a que será un rol algo más
oscuro que en juegos anteriores bueno
esto lo más relevante que se puede
rescatar del tráiler sin duda alguna es
un juego que se ve fantástico comenzando
por el hecho de que gráficamente se ve
genial para esta entrega eso será la
nueva versión del herri engine motor
gráfico usado para varios juegos y la
verdad que todo lo visto en el tráiler
se ve muy bien con un aspecto muy
cuidado y lleno de detalles la
ambientación creo que es un punto en el
juego que se destaca pues esa aldea
nevada y el castillo que por cierto es
el que está lleno de puzzles tiene una
pinta de lo mejor agregando una gran
atmósfera al juego en cuanto a la
historia aún no sabemos mucho de la
historia como tal pero todos estos
detalles como la aldea de los hombres
lobo y un crisis posiblemente malvado
todo apunta que va a tener una historia
supremamente interesante sólo espero que
por fin podamos ver al león a clay guay
y él en este juego conectando la
historia y tan con la de los demás
personajes de la saga
pero bueno ya con este pequeño análisis
de los puntos más relevantes del traer
vamos a la información de la que
disponemos hasta este momento como dije
en el vídeo anterior todo lo que voy a
mencionar son solamente rumores pero
provienen de fuentes muy confiables ya
que estas mismas fuentes son las que nos
han filtran el pasado información de
otros juegos de 'resident evil' además
de hacer quienes visitarán los rumores
de relación y nivel 8 que hasta ahora a
su mayoría terminó siendo confirmados
toda esta información ha sido recopilada
por los usuarios de twitter y bolivia y
varios artículos y faith aquí les
agradezco muchísimo por la información
comencemos por la ambientación del juego
en el vídeo que te comenté hace unos
momentos es en donde los desarrolladores
del juego muestran algunos vistazos
extra sobre el juego me gusta una imagen
de cómo se vería el inventario esto nos
dice dos cosas primero que este nuevo
inventario sea bastante similar al de
héroe 74 en donde podríamos usar el
dinero que vamos recogiendo a través del
juego para comprar objetos armas y
mejoras y segundo se nos muestra que la
moneda que se manejará en el juego son
los ley moneda usada en rumanía con esto
en mente es más que seguro que los
juegos entrará en algún lugar ficticio
ubicado en este lugar ya pasará que nos
muestra un castillo se nos dice que para
este juego podremos explorar lugares
como bosques y cuevas enfocándose
principalmente en la exploración al aire
libre
al igual que otros juegos de este mismo
género esta vez contaremos con una
linterna que tendremos que usar bastante
durante el juego ya que habrá secciones
tan oscuras que serán interna no estará
en posible continuar además de que la
linterna se descargara así que tendremos
que cuidar la batería y usarla con
precaución
y esta no será el único personaje al que
podamos controlar en el juego para esta
nueva entrega jugaremos también como
emily una mujer de más o menos 20 años
que será un habitante de esta aldea
quien estará buscando a su padre a lo
largo de la historia emily ayudará a
irán a adentrarse en esta misteriosa
aldea para después unirse y trabajar
juntos antes de continuar quiero hacer
un aviso desde este punto en adelante
ahora información con posibles spoilers
sobre la historia del juego así que si
no quieres enterarte de nada sobre la
historia te recomiendo que te saltes el
vídeo hasta más o menos aquí listo bien
continuará con información en el tráiler
con todo esto de las brujas y los
hombres luego tal vez algunos piensen
que respiren vivo 8 estará buscando una
ambientación más fantasiosa con magia o
elementos similares pero no el juego al
principio nos dará indicios de cargos
supernatural sucede pero todo esto
resulta ser a causa de que este nuevo
virus se encuentra esparcido en el aire
así causando alucinaciones de vez en
cuando además en el juego se tratara
bastante el tema del ocultismo simulando
algo muy parecido a lo que vemos en
resident tivo 4 con los iluminados ya
que aquí también habrá un culto que a
todas las abominaciones creadas por este
nuevo virus es por eso que hay tanto
simbolismo en algunas imágenes
de atlanta con esta principal del juego
se sabe muy poco sólo conocemos que será
un hombre llamado alan un misterioso
conde que vive en el castillo que vemos
en el tráiler además de ser líder o por
lo menos un miembro bastante importantes
de connections una organización criminal
que se dedica entre otras cosas al
bioterrorismo
pero este misterioso contenido estará
solo porque por lo que parece estar
acompañado por álex wesker la entre
comillas hermanas de albert wesker quien
por si no saben fue el antagonista
principal de resident evil revelations 2
y que en resumen es una mujer que en su
niñez al igual que western fueron parte
de los experimentos conocidos como el
proyecto w a cargo de osvaldo spencer
que buscaba crear una raza evolucionada
de humanos
ya el último dato con spoilers es un
dato bastante importante para la
historia ya que se nos dice que ethan y
mil años después del ocurrió la mansión
biker tuvieron un bebé pero
lamentablemente debido a que tanto izan
como mía fueron expuestos al virus de
evelyn este niño no sería deforme y
mutado es por esto que izan y mia viven
alejados en un lugar remoto para
sepultar a su hijo y protegerlo pero
esto es interrumpido por cris pues al
parecer de alguna manera se entera de la
existencia de este niño y decidirá matar
tanto al niño como a mía aunque sus
razones aún son desconocidas
los desarrolladores del juego
curiosamente comentaron que esta imagen
este símbolo que se muestra
repetidamente durante todo el tráiler
tiene mucha más importancia de lo que
parece pues no está ni siquiera seguros
incluir esta imagen en el tráiler ya que
según palabras de ellos se está
enseñando mucho en esto lo que quiere
decir que este símbolo oculta muchos
secretos que pueden revelar varias cosas
sobre la historia aunque aún nadie sabe
qué significa se te ocurre algo déjame
en los comentarios
ya para el final tenemos algunos datos
menores pero aún relevantes primero el
juego al igual que su predecesor contará
con soporte de realidad virtual ya que
fue un éxito en recibo 7 además y
lamentablemente el juego sólo estará
disponible para pc playstation 5 y xbox
xx no será jugable en playstation 4 ni
next box one como se esperaba así que si
quieren jugar al nuevo resident y boom
me temo que sí o sí y tendrán que
comprar una de las consolas de nueva
generación para jugar en pc y ya como
último a total parecer tanto por las
filtraciones como por la misma página
oficial de resident y 18 todo indica que
en agosto de este mismo año en el state
of play de este mismo mes
presuntamente se revelaría mucho más
sobre el juego como un nuevo tráiler
además de pequeños fragmentos del 33 de
nivel 8
de momento estás toda la información
disponible hasta ahora sobre el nuevo
resident evil que por fin es una
realidad que puedes eso el juego sea
buenísimo con un nivel estético genial
con muchísimos detalles y con una
ambientación que pinta muy muy bien
algunos fans se han visto disgustados
porque no les agradó el hecho de que la
perspectiva en primera persona esté de
vuelta pero creo que es un cambio que le
viene bien a la saga y además aún es muy
pronto para opinar sobre el juego tuvo
que opinar sobre racing y volvió leche
te comprarás una nueva consola para
poder jugarlo o estarás un poco por
ahora sólo tenemos que esperar hasta
agosto para que se revele más
información de fuentes oficiales pero si
se presenta alguna otra información
interesante estar aquí para informarles
hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]